[Musique]
nora a conclu avec un nouveau
fournisseur de cellulaires une entente
de 24 mois et n'a rien payé pour son
nouveau téléphone tout neuf
parce que le coût de son téléphone est
inclus dans son forfait mensuel
cela représente un montant de 20 $ sur
un forfait de 90
nora est convaincu qu'au bout de deux
ans le téléphone sera payée et les 20
dollars
automatiquement souffraient tous de son
forfait
aujourd'hui n'aura se réveille et se
rend compte que son contrat est échu
depuis six mois et que sa facture n'a
pas 18 1 cents elle contacte son
fournisseur qui lui explique qu'il
attendait son appel pour soustraire 20 $
de son paiement mensuel
et il ajoute qu'il avait émis un
avertissement sur sa facture
trois mois avant l'échéance du contrat
comme nora n'a pas réagi il s'est
renouvelée chaque mois aux mêmes
conditions incluant les 20 dollars qui
vont directement dans les poches du
fournisseur oui et le fin mot de
l'histoire
surveillez le moment où se termine votre
contrat de services sans fil
car plus vous laisser le temps file et
plus vous paierez pour rien